e aí galera que assiste o planalto bom
você é esse eu estou ótimo antes de tudo
eu quero avisar a galera do paraná que
eu vou ter um final de semana todinha só
pra eles sexta agora dia 23 de outubro
vai estar em maringá no teatro marista
às sete horas da noite dia 24 de outubro
sábado votar em cascavel paraná no
teatro municipal sete horas da noite do
dia 25 de outubro em londrina paraná no
teatro marista sete horas da noite
é necessário que está aparecendo aqui
até você compra pela internet tem também
a loja que você pode ir lá comprar
retirava encontrei com um fã meu dia de
silvana ele disse que ficou se
identificar muito a minha infância então
eu resolvi contar mais sobre a minha
infância pra vocês eu vou me abrir um
novo tinha mais raiva quando era criança
porque tipo assim a gente erre invés de
sair com os amigos da gente
primeiro a gente passa um dia um dia se
preparando se preparando pra pedir é que
passa um dia se preparam para pedir para
a mãe passar e tem que pedir a deus que
o pai esteja em casa também porque se
você for pedir sua mãe ela vai
desenrolar dizer assim não tem que
esperar seu pai chegar para poder pedir
primeiro que ela é a legenda não dá para
ligar pra ele não branca e thala o pai
tem que falar quando meus amigos
combinava de sair eu te passar um dia um
dia inteiro nossa ae como minha mãe meu
deus nosso senhor que família é lindo
filme bateu em carro indo eu pego ele
pra mim claro claro mãe claro pego água
pego duas água faça chuva essa senhora
quiser e isso tem como vai a casa para
levar ao cinema e claro que eu faço é
que eu limpe com a língua em que passava
o dia inteiro fazendo os gosto dela tem
que passar o dia todo em fazendas gosto
tordin que deu rodava e há muita gente
sabia quem estava fazendo aquilo ali pra
gente pedir ela passar aí para deixar a
gente fazer tudo tudo tudo tudo mãe é
porque amanhã os meus amigos o
aniversário do amigo meu que vai ser na
pizzaria a senhora deixou iria pra gente
colocar assim a ela dar um veredito eu
vou deixar só dessa vez
tcheco
mas sete e meia da noite ataque em casa
mas como é que só tem coragem de falar
pô tá aqui em casa sete horas da noite
mãe é bom falar que a senhora aqui pelo
youtube
como é que a senhora tinha coragem de
dizer pra em cada sete meses de
aniversário começava às 7 horas a mãe
porque os pais da gente tem um modo de
colocar um limite o limite vai até o
ponto onde começa a diversão é ficou na
rede nasce o pai ea mãe olha para o
índice no brasil cresceu menos tão lindo
né meu filho mas ele só não vai se
divertir porque eu não vou deixar mas é
muito lindo sempre que eu sair com meus
amigos era o primeiro até que embora e
quando eu ia pedir pra sair eu tinha que
pedir pra sair pra outro dia não é para
sair hoje principal e vamos fazer vamos
sair hoje 7 horas e horas e não não
aparente patomania meu amigo conhece a
minha mãe eu não vou não vou pedir a ela
tem que ser uma semana antes do poder e
ainda ter que pedir a deus que ele não
mudar de humor que meu pai é o seguinte
eu passar uma semana vai cortando grama
lavando o carro capina no quintal época
caso construindo prédios projeta no
mundo aí eu pedi pra sair ele deixava
ele está assistindo o jogo o time deve
perder se não estás aí você não vai para
lugar nenhum é papai eu tinha deixado
não vai estar comigo é assim quando o
time do meu pai perdia eu já não saía de
casa meu pai torce por vasco daí você já
tinha quando saiu de casa na vida e
ainda torcer por vasco ainda meu deus do
céu fama ganhar baqouba tinha um modo de
fazer meus pais deixar sair de casa é o
seguinte eu sempre fui um grande ato ano
precisa de globo pra isso chegar na
minha mãe é assim
o que é que tu já que é mãe é porque o
meu amigo eu queria pedir passear para
sair
deixa pra lá
a senhora não vai deixar mesmo tudo bem
vai peste pode deixar sair dessa vez já
deixou 'mãe obrigado muito obrigado
tamanho dessa vez eu juro que vou me
comportar tchau
esse é o único jeito de conseguir sair
de casa lá em casa não podia xingaram
phishing gás e lava a mão na boca tão
linda e minha mãe fosse o fato à mãe do
chris é risco meu amigo rochelle o curso
de mães foi aluna da minha mãe não falar
só para aí pô ela a cada mão usada na
cara faz dor mês que eu falei o primeiro
palavra ao pé da minha mãe ainda foi
pior que a minha mãe que tem cuidado ele
que já passou a tocar mais meu dedo
mindinho do pé da cama se eu fosse falar
assim aip que devera roubada em vez de
falar isso é de fácil
ae num novo órgão genital de senhora de
75 anos engrandecido pelo seu uso com
seus parceiros
o povo de filme que senta para conversar
e vamos meu filho venha cá temos uma
coisa importante pra falar com você
aí começa a falar de sexo algo genital
pêlos pubianos na minha casa nunca teve
seu até o 20 anos duas semanas atrás eu
puxei o carro e até cabelos of silva o
meia hora de sexo com pai mãe pra mim
nunca que nunca nem conversei gera raiva
está assistindo filme que é filme para
assistir é duas horas de duração 30
segunda cena de sexo do filme é desse
tamanho é distante até de cena de sexo
na hora que vai passar a ser de sete e
oito atrás do pai e mãe aqui o que é que
você está fazendo posso saber que se
está a assistir pornografia na televisão
e não adianta não me pode assistir no
senhor dos anéis é só ação tiro fechada
para aparecer o pai ea mãe 2000 começa a
atrasar confronto ora amigo tomando
preciosos ligação a meu amigo deixa a
mãe ligar por cabo na tv eu sei o que é
que os pais têm com a gente que ele
ligava pra gente se chamar duas vezes
não atender país que era meu deus do céu
meu filho que tal capotou o carro com um
amigo que estava usando drogas
localizado eles fantasia casa cor na
cabeça um senão eu quero você começa
aqui em baixo uma linha estreita e seus
pais tempo você se você quiser aqui no
youtube e você vai me ajudar muito e
deixar um gostei clicar gostei aqui que
gostei acho demais cada volta lá no
facebook essa postagem de um vídeo novo
aqui lá no facebook deixa eu curtir na
postagem marca nos comentários o amigo
seu que teve uma infância
daqui eu vou tirar foto aqui pois neps
vai ver como foi gravar esse vídeo game
seguinte snappy snaps que aparece na
tela
muito obrigado deste vídeo até aqui
valeu e na ete